Episode 30: America and World War I
Hi I’m John Green, this is Crash Course
U.S. history and today we’re finally going
to make the military history buffs happy.
That’s right, today we’re going to talk
about how the United States with its superior
technology, innovative tactics and remarkable
generalship turned the tide of World War I.
Mr. Green, Mr. Green.
Finally.
I’ve been waiting for months to learn about
tanks and airplanes and Ernest Hemingway.
Well that’s a shame, Me from the Past, because
I was kidding about this being an episode
full of military details.
But I do promise that we will mention Ernest
Hemingway.
And in a few weeks I will tell you about how
he liberated the martinis of Paris.
intro
Americans were only involved in the Great
War for 19 months and, compared with the other
belligerents, we didn’t do much fighting.
Still, the war had profound effects on America
at home, on its place in the world and it
also resulted in an amazing number of war
memorials right here in Indianapolis.
So, The Great War, which lasted from 1914
until 1918, and featured a lot of men with
hats and rifles, cost the lives of an estimated
10 million soldiers.
Also the whole thing was kind of horrible
and pointless, unless you love art and literature
about how horrible and pointless World War
I was in which case, it was a real bonanza.
So, when the war broke out, America remained
neutral, because we were a little bit isolationist
owing to the fact that we were led, of course,
by President Wilson.
But many Americans sided with the British
because by 1914 we’d pretty much forgotten
about all the bad parts of British rule, like
all that tea and monarchy.
Plus, they’re so easy to talk to with their
English.
But there were a significant number of Progressives
who worried that involvement in the war would
get in the way of social reforms at home.
In fact, Wilson courted these groups in the
1916 presidential campaign running on the
slogan “He kept us out of War.”
And will continue to keep us out of war until
we reelect him and then he gets us into war.
But, for that slogan to make sense, there
had to have been some way in which war was
avoided, which brings me to one of the classic
errors made by American history students.
What?
I haven’t even said anything yet.
But you were about to, Me From the Past, because
if I had asked you what event led the U.S.
to enter World War I, you would have surely
told me that it was the sinking of the cruise
ship Lusitania by German submarines.
124 American passengers died when the ship,
which had been carrying arms and also guns,
was torpedoed off the coast of Ireland.
Even though Secretary of State William Jennings
Bryan had warned Americans not to travel on
British, French, or German ships, Wilson refused
to ban such travel because, you know: freedom.
Bryan promptly resigned.
So how do I know it wasn’t the immediate
cause of our involvement in the war?
Because the United States declared war on
Germany and the Central powers on April 2,
1917, almost two years after the sinking of
the Lusitania.
So why did the United States declare war for
only the fourth time in its history?
Was it the Germans’ decision to resume unrestricted
submarine warfare in early 1917?
Was it the interception and publication of
the Zimmerman Telegram in which the German
Foreign Secretary promised to help Mexico
get back California if they joined Germany
in a war against the U.S?
Or was it the fall of the Tsarist regime in
Russia, which made Wilson’s claims that
he wanted to fight to make the world safe
for democracy a bit more plausible?
Yes, yes, and yes.
Also there was our inclination to help Britain,
to whom we had loaned a $2 billion.
That’s the thing about wars.
They never start for easy, simple reasons
like Lusitania sinkings.
Stupid truth, always resisting simplicity.
Oh, it’s time for the Mystery Document?
The rules here are simple.
I guess the author of the mystery document.
I’m either right or I get shocked
I. [or possibly “one”] Open covenants
of peace, openly arrived at, after which there
shall be no private international understandings
of any kind but diplomacy shall proceed always
frankly and in the public view.
II.
[I’m starting to think these are Roman numerals]
Absolute freedom of navigation upon the seas,
outside territorial waters, alike in peace
and in war, except as the seas may be closed
in whole or in part by international action
for the enforcement of international covenants
III.
The removal, so far as possible, of all economic
barriers and the establishment of an equality
of trade conditions among all the nations
consenting to the peace and associating themselves
for it’s maintenance.
[And] XIV.
[I’m going to guess we skipped some.]
A general association of nations must be formed
under specific covenants for the purpose of
affording mutual guarantees of political independence
and territorial integrity of great and small
states alike.
Stan, thank you for throwing me a softball.
That’s my favorite kind of ball.
Other than you, Wilson.
With its mention of self-determination, freedom
of the seas, open diplomacy, and liberal use
of Roman numerals, I know it is Woodrow Wilson’s
Fourteen Points.
Our second consecutive Woodrow Wilson week
and my second consecutive non-shock.
Given all of his quasi-imperialism, there’s
something a little bit ideologically inconsistent
about Wilson, but his Fourteen Points are
pretty admirable as a statement of purpose.
Most of them deal specifically with colonial
possessions, and were pretty much ignored,
but I suppose if we have learned anything,
it’s that in American history, it’s the
thought that counts.
[Libertage]
America’s primary contribution to the Entente
powers winning the war was economic as we
sent all sorts of arms and money “over there.”
Troops didn’t arrive until the spring of
1918 and eventually over 1 million American
doughboys served under General John J. Pershing.
Not all of these people saw combat.
They were much more likely to die of flu than
bullet wounds, but their sheer numbers were
enough to force the defeat of the exhausted
Germans.
And now, as promised, I will mention Ernest
Hemingway.
He served as an ambulance driver, which gave
him a close up view of death and misery and
led to his membership in the so called Lost
Generation of writers who lived in Paris in
the 1920s and tried to make sense of everything.
Turns out, it’s pretty hard to make sense
of and you’re just going to end up with
a lot of six-toed cats and then eventually
suicide.
Okay, so I said earlier than a lot of American
Progressives were anti-war, but certainly
not all of them.
Like, according to Randolph Bourne, “War
is the health of the state.”
And for progressives like him, “the war
offered the possibility of reforming American
society along scientific lines, instilling
a sense of national unity and self-sacrifice,
and expanding social justice.”
Let’s go to the ThoughtBubble.
World War I made the national government much
more powerful than it had ever been.
Like, in May of 1917, Congress passed the
selective service act, which required 24 million
men to register for the draft and eventually
increased the size of the army from 120,000
to 5 million.
The government also commandeered control of
much of the economy to get the country ready
to fight, creating new agencies to regulate
industry, transportation, labor relations,
and agriculture.
The War Industries Board took charge of all
elements of wartime production setting quotas
and prices and establishing standardized specification
for almost everything, even down to the color
of shoes.
The Railroad Administration administered transportation,
and the Fuel Agency rationed coal and oil.
This regulation sometimes brought about some
of the progressives’ goals.
Like, the War Labor Board, for instance, pushed
for a minimum wage, eight hour days and the
rights of workers to form unions.
Wages rose substantially in the era, working
conditions improved and union membership skyrocketed.
But then so did taxes, and the wealthiest
Americans ended up on the hook for 60% of
their income.
Also, in World War I as never before, the
government used its power to shape public
opinion.
In 1917 the Wilson administration created
the Committee on Public Information, which
only sounds like it’s from an Orwell novel.
Headed by George Creel, the CPI’s team created
a wave of propaganda to get Americans to support
the war, printing pamphlets, making posters
and advertising in swanky motion pictures.
The best known strategies were the speeches
of 75,000 four minute men, who in that amount
of time delivered messages of support for
the war in theaters, schools, and other public
venues.
The key concepts in the CPI propaganda effort
were democracy and freedom.
“Creel believed that the war would accelerate
movement towards solving the “age old problems
of poverty, inequality, oppression, and unhappiness,”
because, obviously, war is the most effective
antidepressant.
Thanks, Thoughtbubble.
So the aforementioned Randolph Bourne might
have had good things so say about war, but
he was also correct when he suggested that
the war would encourage and empower the “least
democratic forces in American life.”
World War I may have been a war to make the
world safe for democracy but according to
one historian “the war inaugurated the most
intense repression of civil liberties the
nation has ever known.”
War suppressing civil liberties, eh?
I’m glad those days have passed.
Speaking of the repression of civil liberties,
the NSA is about to start watching this video
because I’m about to use the word “espionage.”
The Espionage act of 1917 prohibited spying,
interfering with the draft and “false statements”
that might impede military success.
Even more troubling was the Sedition Act passed
in 1918, which criminalized statements that
were intended to cast “contempt, scorn or
disrepute” on our form of government or
that advocated interference with the war effort.
So basically these laws made it a crime to
criticize either the war or the government.
In fact, Eugene Debs, the Socialist who ran
for president in 1912, was one of those convicted
for giving an anti-war speech.
He was sentenced to 10 years in prison and
he served three of them, but he ran for president
from prison and got 900,000 votes.
Fortunately, thanks to checks and balances,
you can turn to the courts.
Unfortunately, they weren’t very helpful.
Like in Schenck v. the U.S., the Supreme Court
upheld the conviction of a guy named Schenck
for encouraging people to avoid the draft
and ruled that the government can punish critical
speech when it presents a “clear and present
danger,” to the state and its citizens.
This was when Justice Oliver Wendell Holmes
introduced the famous exception to free speech,
that it is not okay to “shout fire in a
crowded theater.”
Nor apparently is it okay to shout, “We
shouldn’t be in this war, I don’t think.
Just my opinion.”
But, some went even further.
The 250,000 strong American Protective League
helped the Justice Department identify radicals
by harassing people in what were called “slacker
raids.”
Good thing those stopped before you got to
high school, right Me from the Past?
Slacker.
In Bisbee, Arizona vigilantes went so far
to put striking copper miners in boxcars,
shipped them out to the middle of the desert
and left them there.
The war also raised the question of what it
meant to be a ‘real American.’
Like, public schools “Americanized” immigrants
and sought to “implant in their children,
so far as can be done, the Anglo-Saxon conceptions
of righteousness, law and order, and popular
government.”
Many cities sponsored Americanization pageants,
especially around the Fourth of July, which
the CPI in 1918 re-christened “Loyalty Day”.
Hamburgers, a German word, became liberty
sandwiches.
World War I certainly didn’t create anti-immigrant
feeling in the United States, but it was used
to justify it.
Like, IQ tests, introduced to screen army
applicants, were soon used to argue that certain
immigrant groups were inferior to white protestants
and could never be fully assimilated into
the United States.
Now, of course, those tests were tremendously
biased, but no matter.
But, to return to the questions of dissent
and free speech, the suppression continued
after the war with the 1919 Palmer Raids,
for instance, named after Attorney General
A. Mitchell Palmer and headed up by a young
J. Edgar Hoover.
To be fair, someone did try to blow up Palmer.
So there was some dissent related to the suppression
of dissent.
Also, more than 4 million workers engaged
in strikes in the United States in 1919 but
that didn’t legally justify the arrest of
more than 5,000 suspected radicals and labor
organizers.
Most of them were arrested without warrants
and held without charge, sometimes for months.
And it’s difficult to imagine that all of
this would have happened without the heightened
sense of patriotism that always accompanies
war.
However, there were a handful of good things
to come out of the Great War, and not just
the stylings of Irving Berlin.
Like, students are often taught that the war
led directly to the passage of the 19th amendment,
although a number of states had actually granted
the franchise to women before the war.
In Montana, for instance, women didn’t just
vote, they held office.
Congresswoman Jeannette Rankin voted against
the declaration of war in 1917, and was the
only member of the House to vote against the
declaration of war against Japan in 1941.
New opportunities in wartime industry also
provided incentives for African Americans
to move north, thus beginning the so-called
great migration and the growth of black populations
in northern cities like Chicago and New York.
The biggest gain was in Detroit where between
1910 and 1920 the black population rose from
5,741 to 40,838, a 611% increase.
So it’s true that World War I provided some
new opportunities for African Americans and
women, but if World War I was supposed to
be an opportunity for America to impose its
progressive ideas on the rest of the world,
it failed.
The Versailles peace conference where Wilson
tried to implement his 14 Points raised hope
for a new diplomatic order.
But, the results of the treaty made the 14
points look hypocritical.
I mean, especially when Britain and France
took control of Germany’s former colonies
and carved up the Arabian provinces of the
Ottoman Empire into new spheres of influence.
Wilson’s dream of a League of Nations was
realized, but the U.S. never joined it largely
because Congress was nervous about giving
up its sovereign power to declare war.
And disappointment over the outcome of World
War I led the U.S. to, for the most part,
retreat into isolationism until World War
II.
And therein lies the ultimate failure of World
War I.
It’s not called “The World War,” it’s
called “World War I,” because then we
had to go and have a freaking other one.
We’ll talk about that in a few weeks, but
next week we get to talk about suffrage.
Yes!
We finally did something right.
I’ll see you then.
Crash Course is produced and directed by Stan
Muller.
Our script supervisor is Meredith Danko.
The associate producer is Danica Johnson.
The show is written by my high school history
teacher Raoul Meyer, Rosianna Rojas, and myself.
And our graphics team is Thought Café.
Every week, there’s a new caption for the
Libertage.
If you’d like to suggest one, you can do
so in comments where you can also ask questions
about today’s video that will be answered
by our team of historians.
Thanks for watching Crash Course and as we
say in my hometown, don’t forget to be awesome.
Stan, can you do some movie magic to get me
out of here?
Perfect.